we have two brand new agents in this  film who are allies to james bond the  world's moved on commander bond you were  double o two years nomi is highly  skilled slightly cocky you get in my way  i will put a bullet in your knee  the one that works  there's a young lady in santiago i want  you to meet hello  you're late  paloma is a cuban agent she's intense  i had many action scenes  thank god i had an amazing stunt team  they put me through a true military  training i really wanted to get it right  and looked like i knew what i was doing  no time to die represents change we see  so many different examples of women  being strong in this movie  and being badass is at that do you ever  flow this nope  salute  [Music]  you